lancelin pitches he likes to throw he
likes to throw a fastball four seamer
and a cutter he has taken the input of
this staff to kind of refine himself and
evolve as a pitcher and the cat's own
one to ramon lariano
and the next pitch to ramon is a bouncy
ball to third frazier goes to second for
one a double clutch by odor throws
deferred throws it by santana it hits
off the side wall karen's back of the
first baseman so the rangers get the
force at second 5-4 on simeon lauriano
is safe at first this guy's been saddled
himself that is marcana
hits it hard and that's a base hit to
center field
lorianno hustling around third he's
going to come in to score another two
out hit for marcanna and the a's take a
one-nothing lead oh he is so good he is
so good he's dhing and you know takes it
right back up the middle with a big two
out
rbi single and bottom line mark cannon
knows how to hit kind of knows almost
exactly what a pitcher is going to be
trying to do against it
well big 3-2 the runners go this one in
the air out to right field heinemann on
the run and will go into a slide to make
the catch
and in the inning
oakland gets one run out of it lynn
pitches out of the jam and now the
rangers go to work i'm gonna cash in a
couple of runs right here you have the
guy you want up there frazier's just
been so consistent lizardo's one two and
this one up the middle base hit that'll
get at least one home here comes santana
the throwheaded plate
it's cut off
a two-run single by frazier and the
rangers strike right back in the first
to take the lead
he comes back with a change up away
which really
sounds like a pretty good idea
you've just shown him your best fastball
you come back with a pretty good change
up tailing away on the outside corner
and the batter serves it into center
field for two runs two to one ranger is
top of the second he has come up with
biscotti kemp and murphy against lance
lynn
and the pistol biscotti has driven to
deep left center field solace back deep
in the alley in that one is gone
on the first pitch biscotti sees in the
top of the second he drills a home run
left center field number five this year
and he is tied the game at 2-2 biscotti
swung in the bat so well got an elevated
fastball belt tied
i mean this ball is crushed and that's
the a's bullpen guys that that's right
there oh years is he kind of fuller
and connor falefa shoots this one in the
air out to right field piscotty's back
and that one is gone trainer falefa with
his first home run of the season and
he's given the rangers the three to two
lead that's a pretty good example you
know you hear some players say boy this
ballpark is too big oh there you've got
a kid who's not known for his power
going the opposite way and hitting it
385 feet out of the ballpark now tavares
who struck out to start the ranger first
in his first big league at bat
2-0 pitch line drive left field that's a
base hit royalty tavares with his first
big league hit hello that's single to
left field here we go nice smile on the
face congrats
get him the baseball change up down and
away well not died down a little bit not
away right in the middle of the plate
and hopefully that's the first of many
got his first big league at bat
now his first big league hit he's got
speed too so robinson back off the
injured list hit the ball hard to center
field in the first inning
this one up the middle off the second
base bag and into short center field and
he is
going to settle for the single wow
how did he catch that ball
it almost killed them loriano throws a
one hop around the run
watch the catch by the second baseman
it's a ball right off the end of the
back spinning slicing off the bag you
see tony cap right here
he dives to get out of the way the ball
stuck in his glove
lance lynn done for the night after six
great innings again and he leaves with a
three to two lead struck out eight lance
lynn really had his way
right-hander jonathan hernandez comes
out of the bullpen he may give up some
hits zra is not zero but it's just very
hard for me to imagine that there are
many hitters going up there and saying
boy i can't wait to get my bat against
this guy
olson
flies out on the first pitch and that
was an 11-pitch inning so runners at
first and third 16th appearance for
rasmira petit first base side of the
mound long hold now pitches and a
fastball has hit the left
not very deep in and overcomes grossman
robbie's going to get there make the
catch nice job by petite one pitch
cleans it up 3-2
kemp now is at third he's the tying run
simeon is at second he's the go ahead
run and loriano is at first base and
olson is the batter he's ahead one and
two
and
got him looking
two gone in the inning and a huge
strikeout for montero
he's definitely trying to throw the ball
down there he's trying not to throw a
strike and get a call
and all those pitches are right near the
bottom of the strike zone a huge call
and a big strikeout and now for the
bases loaded matt chapman will be the
hitter trying to get another one right
here to end it
one two
in the air right field not gonna carry
heineman is there
and this one is over the rangers take
the opener from oakland
three to two and they put that losing
streak to bed great way to start a very
important home stand for the rangers